i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story
my name is elena morris but you may know
me as overly attached girlfriend
this all started in 2012. i was 20 years
old
in school to become a teacher i had
actually just taken a break
and i was working part-time at a place
called
pack and mail just living with my
college roommates
going to work life was pretty normal in
the back of my mind
like if i could have done anything i
would have moved to la
and done acting or writing or something
like that but i wasn't
confident enough in that happening for
me to really take that
leap so i was in my
apartment looking online at just like
you know the daily justin bieber news as
you do
and i came across a contest
that justin bieber was having he had hit
song at the time
called boyfriend and he was releasing a
new fragrance
called girlfriend so he asked fans
to make a parody song from the
girlfriend's perspective
so i got really excited and started
writing lyrics
right away i was a justin bieber fan i
mean keep in mind
i was 20 years old and justin bieber was
like a teenager i wasn't
really like obsessed with him i think it
was kind of fun like silly music that i
enjoyed but it wasn't like a real
obsession like a lot of people may think
it was
when it came to the lyrics of the song i
knew that i wanted it to be funny
his original lyrics i think are i'll
never let you go
and so i just kind of took that and made
it to the extreme
and that kind of took off from there if
i was your girlfriend i'd drive you up
the wall
question here with yeah i'd always call
and call i wasn't actually
speaking from experience the creepy face
was definitely like a last minute
decision so i was on like my fourth take
of this song and i realized that there's
this really long
instrumental period of time at the
beginning of the song where i was just
sitting there not doing anything
so i just sort of decided to stare
straight into my webcam and make the
creepiest face
i could make i had no idea how
profoundly this would affect my life
i posted the video to youtube for the
contest the night of june 6th and then i
think like right after that i shared it
to my
facebook page it was before i went to
bed that night that
i knew people that i didn't know in real
life were watching it i remember
my roommates and i were staying up
watching the numbers come in
and there was like 52 comments at one
point and i knew that i didn't know 52
people
that would take the time to watch and
especially comment on the video
and then i went to bed and then i woke
up and it was a lot bigger
than it was the night before my first
memory of that day
is walking out into my living room and
my roommates turning their computers
toward me and saying
you're a meme and that's when i realized
my face was
everywhere all day i was just getting
like texts from my friends
and seeing comments online and i
couldn't get online without seeing
my own creepy face staring back at me
like my friends and i thought it was
mostly just funny like i
i feel like i'm really lucky that i was
in on the joke i know that's not the
case for
a lot of other people that kind of wake
up and realize their face is all over
the internet and they've become a meme
but
there was no negativity at first it was
just like all really really cool
positive like what's happening this is
crazy
at the time call me maybe by carly rae
jepsen was really popular and so
people were asking for that very
specific parody for me to do and i
wasn't sure
like if i should keep it going or just
like let it be
what it was i didn't want to milk it for
too long
i decided to go ahead and do it and the
second video blew up and then
the number one and number two top spots
on youtube were both my videos
that is kind of when i realized like
okay maybe i should
kind of ride this wave and go along with
this and
make it into something i was on youtube
and i did
a bunch of different like sketches
interview type things and vlogs
i got to be on the red carpet at the
american music awards
i also got to go to singapore where i
had a staring contest
on stage with jessica alba which was
like simultaneously one of the coolest
and weirdest things that's ever
happened to me i lost during the
rehearsal but i won the real thing
and jeremy piven was playing a drum an
important
side note there i got asked by delta to
be
in an airline safety video i was on set
with all of these like
meme and internet people i think all of
us were kind of thinking
like why like why us why this
concept and after the video was posted i
think the entire internet
kind of wondered the exact same thing
but it didn't take away from the fact
that it was so fun it was a cool
experience to meet
other people that had kind of gone
through similar things
anyone who's like become a viral meme we
all have a very similar
story while also being like vastly
vastly
different all of these like really cool
opportunities were happening and i was
on youtube and things were going really
well
but it did get to the point after maybe
about a year
of doing this where i started to feel
just like a ton of pressure
to figure out what the end goal was did
i want to pursue acting
or stand up did i want to write did i
need to move to los
angeles i felt like really overwhelmed
and stressed if i didn't have a video
idea
then i would just be like beating myself
up about it every day
all day and it was still really fun
which i think is part of why it was so
difficult and confusing
i know now looking back that i sort of
um
landed myself in this depression around
like 2014 especially is when it got
really bad but i i didn't know it at the
time you know like i kind of thought
well i have all these great
opportunities and i have this great life
and i'm making money and like i'm not
depressed it's just it's just i'm stuck
or i'm lazy or i'm not i can't find the
motivation
i was in therapy for about nine months
before i made the decision to
try medication i had a tough time with
it i remember i
when i first picked up my prescription i
cried in the parking lot of the pharmacy
because
i just didn't want to need it i didn't
want to have to like
rely on this pill going into my body to
feel better but at the end of the day
like
i knew that anything was better
than how i was feeling then and it
worked for me and so it's important for
me to
kind of get that message out there that
it does work for some and it doesn't
work for others and
i think if that's something that you
need to do for yourself that is really
really important that you remember that
all you're doing is taking care of you
i kind of knew that if i ever walked
away if i ever
officially decided like okay i'm done
with youtube i didn't want to leave
without a goodbye video my story
is a little bit unique right like not
everyone becomes a meme
but my mental health part of that story
is
not unique at all and in fact since
posting my video what i've learned
is it's actually incredibly common for
people to feel the way that i felt
i'm still online i'm still on instagram
and twitter and i still
kind of look at the numbers and and care
a little bit but it's just not
it doesn't take over my life i guess the
way that it used to
looking back at everything that happened
i'm super super grateful
my life in literally every
possible way changed completely
overnight
and there were so many highs and there
were so many lows
and i look back at that time with a lot
of fondness
i'm very happy that it happens and i
think
overly attached girlfriend is like the
best thing
that's ever happened to me
[Music]